president obama did four fundraisers
last week a lot of people giving him
[ __ ] for all the fundraisers and the
golf and all that stuff i don't want to
focus on that but he had an interesting
quote about everything that's been going
on and and the media's relation to
making us all crazy let's take a look he
said i can see why a lot of folks are
troubled the world's always been messy
we're just noticing now in part because
of social media if you watch the nightly
news it feels like the world is falling
apart but it's been challenging for
quite a while we will get through these
challenging times just like we have in
the past okay
now I'm sort of on board with a little
of that right I mean we see all this
stuff now we see the beheadings
immediately we don't have to wait for
the nightly news we get all the videos
all that stuff on the other hand the
media is being pretty soft on the guy so
it seems like it's a little disingenuous
it's not about being soft on Obama it's
what the media feeds the public and how
they shape what's going on in the world
and this is communications 101 stuff
right the media has a bias their job is
to if it bleeds it leads and if it's if
there's any kind of drama if there's a
need for Superman to come along to solve
something they will put that on the TV
and so completely we are inundated and
so you have the nightly news which has
always been horrific I mean if you live
to the Vietnam era nightly news was
pretty grim Nixon Vietnam all that kind
of stuff all the way through but now you
have the echo chamber now everybody's
putting it on their Facebook wall in
there is this and my opinion to this and
tweeted it it's so it feels like the
same news story you're now seeing it
probably 10 or a hundred times a day
yeah it affects the brain
so does it affect your brain because I
definitely think it does Kelley and I
have talked about this a lot that you're
constantly if you have your phone and
your and your Twitter and we're gonna
talk about this later also but if you
have this stuff yours being slammed by
this information repeatedly so does
Obama at least have a point there that
it maybe seems worse now just because of
the accent do you mean like that the
media is turned into AM radio it's
that you know since since the hostage
crisis between you know Reagan and
Carter when they went to the 24-hour
news cycle it's now basically Billy
don't be a hero
except it's Billy don't blow up or
behead anybody in the in the Middle East
I mean they their objectivity gone their
impartiality gone there Bart they're
bought and paid for is what's there the
24-hour news cycle is just beating us to
death like AM radio can make you like
Katrina and the waves walking on
sunshine I actually have that song in my
head from 1987 because of the repetition
which is now a part of our news news
right you got to just keep that song
going just so you can get through the
day yeah I mean if you're on the right
and you're watching fox or if you're on
the left and you're watching MSNBC
you're basically a star Belly's nature
or a sneech without a star but you're
just cranking the same 15 minutes and it
goes from each talking head right and if
you lived before this period of time you
realize that that's not what the media
the news is supposed to be yeah it
bleeds it leads was not part of the
problem yeah you know it's that it
bleeds it leads brought to you by dial
you know for a manly wash of the blood
that's all over your hands now yeah this
is we talk about this all the time they
look if you turn on Fox you're getting
Republican parties you if you turn on
MSNBC you're getting the administration
so you turn on CNN they're putting up
just people on both sides but then
there's no analysis they don't tell you
what the truth is
they just put up PR guys on both sides
so I get okay so we're all with
Holograms the Holograms are good though
I like the holiday we'll be doing this
by Holograms by next year all right so I
get it we all leave so we all hate the
media okay media sucks we're all on
board that theory but is there still
something a little is it possible that
what he's saying is true and not true so
with the media sucks we're all on board
that but then is it possible that things
are worse now but we can't possibly
can't filter it properly because of all
that this nonsense does don't think seem
a little worse now like there's so much
[ __ ] going on between Ukraine and Gaza
Syria and Iraq and Poland like is it
possible that things maybe are worse
there is a lot going on and I think
there's always a lot going on and and we
are just so interconnected now there's
there's very few walls between towns
nations villages and there's no walls
and and so we're just it's a lot of
information and yes maybe it's a little
bit of a spike of horribleness and it
yes I mean it's been a bad month it
feels like it's been a bad month you
know and and it's difficult but this is
where I think education the education
system really needs to change media
literacy needs to start in kindergarten
yeah kids need to learn that when they
go to a website or they turn on a
channel or they're looking at a Twitter
feed that someone is saying something
based on an opinion there's you know
that unless you're a scientist in
reading a science paper which is still
got a little bias in it because it's a
human there is a bias going on people
want to sell you their there's their
side of things so I think the perception
is reality you know I think things are
worse and I have the perspective of time
and in a different news cycle and a
different repetition a different
frequency repetitive frequency of a news
story I believe that things are worse
and I think that what you're asking for
to teach the children does happen my
daughter had an assignment when she was
in grade school which dealt with
Wikipedia as a source and how dangerous
that could be and the teacher actually
went through and told everybody to use
Wikipedia for this this paper they were
writing and then went through and
dispelled but some idiot just put up a
fact you know no Isis is not being led
by Sacha Baron Cohen it would be even
though he sounds like that guy either
you can't read that on wiki and take it
as a fact but it does come back to this
thing about the media in that they've
lost their credibility so we have the
frequency you know it's it's a brisket
without the meat which is basically a
bone we're boned you know we don't have
anybody being object I mean shows like
this and other shows are in certain
markets the online world can have some
reality to it but even there you have
another person or and
just frequency throwing lies and
factoids which are non facts so until we
can figure out a way to get that
objectivity back and get the the profit
center out of news out of media which is
really the problem we're gonna be in
trouble we're gonna be all chasing the
wrong facts over and over and over every
15 minutes on the hour so to that point
last question on this I kind of feel
like because we don't trust the media
and because we don't trust our
politicians I've been feeling lately I
think it's sort of kicked in over the
summer that we kind of don't know what
America is anymore
like there's a real feeling amongst
amongst I'm not talking about the left
and the right but like pretty much
everybody else which is most of us even
though they make it seem like the
rational people are only a tiny bit it's
most of us I think that we don't we just
don't know what we are anymore like are
we the interventionists are we the
peaceniks are we do you feel that - yeah
and even even more than that like more
than policy it's like whoo what you know
the institutions are all going away who
do we trust yous got who's got the facts
who's got just a real rational
perspective on anything we don't trust
government we don't trust big business
we don't trust media we don't trust you
know we don't trust anyone and so we're
having to find our own kind of energy PS
with all of this and I think that's part
of feeding all of the frenzy - is like
you know we're looking for information
I'm willing to give you more information
and I think it's a natural outcome of
modern society the breakdown of of
institutions what's going on and I you
know we're in the middle of it we're in
the middle of the chaos of all of this
yeah trying to end this on a positive
note is there something good out of that
could something good come out of us
having to sorta recenter ourselves
because if we don't trust the
institutions we have to trust ourselves
give me something some oh absolutely
absolutely and there's an app for it I'm
gonna pull it up